freunde der sonne fast ich das hier
nicht sagt kokosöl ist das reine gift
dann dann seid ihr noch später dran als
ich etwa 1,3 millionen menschen und auch
viele von euch haben die kokosöl
kontroverse mitbekommen hätte eigentlich
bis gestern noch versucht frau professor
michels für ein interview hier bei meile
zu gewinnen
doch jetzt hat sie leider abgesagt aus
zeitlichen gründen weil sie anscheinend
von anfragen nur so bombardiert wird nun
dachte ich erst muss ich dieses video
jetzt über machen denn das thema fette
und öle steht sowieso schon länger auf
meiner to-do-liste und das video wird
dieses jahr auch noch kommen
aber weil es so viele menschen immer
noch darüber reden und dabei die
wichtigsten punkte
meiner meinung nach immer noch nicht
erwähnt wurden hole ich das jetzt nach
okay ganz ganz kurz was ist jetzt
eigentlich mit dem kokosöl hätte
bestehen aus fettsäuren fettsäuren sind
langkettigen molekülen das sind ketten
von kohlenstoff atomen am ende ist eine
säure gruppe und je nachdem wie diese
kohlenstoffatom kette ziemlich genau
aufgebaut ist kann man fette in
verschiedene gruppen unterteilen
es gibt gesättigte fettsäuren und
ungesättigte fettsäuren gesättigten
fettsäuren haben nur einfach bindungen
ungesättigte fettsäuren haben auch
doppelbindung und die hier mit dem
doppel bindungen die kann man nochmal
unterteilen ob es so weil es so schön es
gibt einfach ungesättigte die haben eine
doppelbindung und mehrfach ungesättigte
ja mehrere doppelbindung die kommen
jetzt so in der natur vor man kann aber
auch gesättigte fettsäuren nehmen also
welche ohne doppel bindungen und die
doppelbindung künstlich hinzufügen dabei
entstehen sogenannte transfette bis
ihnen alles klar sobald wir diese dinge
jetzt aber in unserem und ton und essen
und die dann in unserem stoffwechsel in
andere stoffe umgewandelt werden und das
ganze dann auch noch über jahre oder
eine längere zeit hinweg passiert dann
wird es richtig kompliziert mark my
worlds nichts
ernährung ist einfach nichts aber ich
werde jetzt trotzdem stark vereinfachen
aber auch nur weil zu fetten und ölen
ohnehin noch ein ausführliches video
kommen wird müsste man jetzt ein
allgemeines ranking aufstellen
dann wären die trans fettsäuren die
schlechtesten danach kämen die
gesättigten fettsäuren danach die
ungesättigten fettsäuren und bei denen
die mehrfach ungesättigten fettsäuren
also die mit mehreren doppel bindungen
im schnitt bisschen besser als die
einfach ungesättigten fettsäuren weil
zudem mehrfach ungesättigten auch die
essentiellen gehöre essentiell bedeutet
der körper braucht diese fettsäuren kann
sie aber selbst nicht herstellen bei
menschen sind es zwei habt ihr bestimmt
auch schon gehört eine omega 3
fettsäuren omega 6 fettsäure die sollten
die also essen weil wir sie halt nicht
erstrecke
das ist halt eine geschichte für sich
deswegen habe ich es ausgeklammert trans
habe ich jetzt auch mal ausgeklammert
weil es diese künstlich gehärtete fette
sind die man nach möglichkeit vermeiden
sollte aber bei den natürlich
vorkommenden städten sind die
ungesättigten im schnitt besser als die
gesättigten und kokosöl von allen
natürlichen fetten den größten anteil an
gesättigten fettsäuren hat nämlich 92
prozent sagt professor michael ist
kokosöl ist das reine gift ich habe
schon seit anfang an gesagt kokosöl ist
es reine gift also ich informiere sie
hier nur sie können nachher natürlich
mit den informationen tun und lassen was
sie wollen
fakt ist kokosöl ist das reine gift für
die formulierung dass reine gift hat
sich professor michael ist inzwischen
öffentlich entschuldigt und das
zugespitzt bezeichnet mir ist das nicht
ihre einzige zugespitzte aussage
gesättigte fettsäuren verstopfen ihrer
herzkranke face kann's gefäße und führen
zum sicheren herztod
also hier ist es doch jetzt nicht mehr
rhetorisch zugespitzt das ist doch
medizinisch konkret führen zum sicheren
herztod um ein paar dinge klarzustellen
professor mich jetzt im nachgang ein
offizielles statement veröffentlicht da
sind ein paar wissenschaftliche quellen
verlinkt die ich mir genauer angeschaut
habe wenn man das versucht
zusammenzufassen dann geht es in diesen
quellen vor allem umwelt gesättigte
versus ungesättigte fette im allgemeinen
selten um kokosöl im speziellen aber und
kokosöl geht es gibt zwar nicht viel
taten dazu aber die sagen das kokosöl
nicht so schlecht ist wie man aufgrund
des hohen gesättigten fettsäuren anteils
erwarten würde
hier steht man kann die wirkung einer
fettsäure im körper nicht voraussagen
allein auf basis des gesättigten
fettsäuren teils aber professor michels
macht genau das in ihrem vortrag obwohl
sie diese quellen selbst verlegt hat
dazu hätte ich sie jetzt gerne genauer
befragt tatsächlich ist kokosöl laut
ihrer eigenen quellen eben nicht die
gründung der schlechten vettel also es
ist nicht gesund es gibt keine
wissenschaftlich nachgewiesen
gesundheitlichen vorteile nur nachteile
deshalb jetzt sinnvoll noch kokosöl zu
verzichten und stattdessen zum beispiel
sonnenblumen hinzunehmen aber es ist auf
demselben level wie zum beispiel butter
oder palmöl zwei sachen von denen wir
viel mehr konsumieren trend hin oder her
in ihrem vortrag spricht professor mich
jetzt aber nicht nur über kokosöl
sondern auch über kasan café spinat
gluten wasser vegetarismus wenn ich
jetzt nicht im ganzen vortrag ein
wissenschaftlich geprüft machen wollte
dann wäre ich jetzt ein jahr lang damit
beschäftigt ich kann ich aber ein paar
allgemeine sachen sagen für eure
sogenannte scientific sie also eure
fähigkeit als laien wissenschaft selbst
einzuordnen eine frage die hier bei
meile in den kommentaren immer wieder
auftaucht ist wie kann ich als laie
seriöse von unseriösen
wissenschaftlichen quellen unterscheiden
es gibt jetzt keine ultimativen zehn
punkte guide aber es gibt zum beispiel
doch so gewisse red flags an denen man
nicht seriöse quellen erkennen kann oder
die darauf hinweisen sage ich mal so und
einen major red flag sind kassel also
starke und differenziertes und deswegen
war ich
also ich das hier gehört habe kokosöl
ist das reine gift völlig verwirrt ich
habe mir den vortrag inzwischen zweimal
komplett angeschaut aber beim ersten mal
dachte ich bei der stelle wo sie sagt
kokos das reine gibt oder macht jetzt
eine pause gibt dachte ich das ist ein
witz ich dachte sie hat das jetzt aus
witz überspitzt formuliert und löst den
witz jetzt gleich wieder auf ich habe
darauf gewartet aber ne frau vermisst
und ich haben verschiedene art und
weisen wissenschaft zu vermitteln
direkter vergleich das heißt wenn sie zu
viel fruchtzucker zu sich nehmen kriegen
sie eine leberverfettung ob und
inwieweit struktur so eine fettleber
verursachen kann ist eine ernst
zunehmende sorge ist aber noch nicht
wissenschaftlich geklärt aber man muss
sagen professor michels bietet nur das
was alle hören wollen wenn es um
ernährung geht nämlich service tipps und
handlungsempfehlungen alle möchten
wissen wie die sich wissenschaftlich
korrekt am besten ernähren und sie
möchten einfache klare tipps und die
bekommen sie auch das kokosöl ist eines
der schlimmsten nahrungsmittel die sie
überhaupt zu sich nehmen können also bei
manchen aussagen wäre ich ja noch
einverstanden wenn man das nicht als
feste regel sondern als grobe faustregel
kommunizieren würde aber manche
servicetipps gehen nicht so weit wenn
sie insbesondere eine familiengeschichte
von herz kreislauf erkrankungen haben
und deswegen auch gerne selber sich für
herz kreislauf krankheiten schützen
wollen würde ich ihnen die mehrfach
ungesättigten fettsäuren empfehlen wenn
sie insbesondere eine familiengeschichte
von krebs haben und sich vor krebs
schützen wollen die einfach
ungesättigten fettsäuren dass sie so
ganz nonchalant obwohl der
gesundheitliche unterschied zwischen den
einfach und mehrfach ungesättigten
fettsäuren laut ihrer eigenen quellen
noch lange nicht geklärt ist sondern
andere aussagen sind schlicht und
einfach falsch kohlensäure führt leider
informierte maße zu bluthochdruck und
auf einer übersäuerung des körpers aber
meisten stört es nicht dass hier
ernährung als etwas einfaches oder
zumindest etwas klares
dargestellt wird solange man nur die
expertin hat die einem die daten verrät
also ich informiere sie hier nur sie
können nachher natürlich mit den
informationen tun und lassen was sie
wollen
ich danke euch was freunde der sonne
ganz wichtige lektion für eure
scientific literacy wissenschaftliche
daten und ergebnisse sind wertlos
solange ihr nicht wisst wie man an diese
ergebnisse bekommen ist wann immer euch
irgendjemand etwas über
wissenschaftliche ergebnisse erzielt
müsst ihr euch über die sogenannte
methodik informieren das bedeutet wie
wurden diese daten überhaupt erhoben und
wie man sie ausgewertet oder diese infos
könnt ihr wissenschaft nicht richtig
interpretieren wird wohl kommen jetzt
ergebnisse von ernährungs studien zum
beispiel kann man mit hilfe von
fragebögen infos über menschen
herausfinden zum beispiel was sie essen
wie oft sie irgendwas wissen wie viel
sie sich bewegen und so weiter und dann
kann man diese infos vergleichen mit
medizinischen daten von diesen menschen
die man halt technisch messen kann und
dann kann man schauen was es da für
zusammenhänge gibt und dann könnte zum
beispiel heraus kommen menschen die
extrem viel butter essen leiden öfter an
herzinfarkten das schwierige daran ist
dass menschen die sehr viel butter essen
statistisch gesehen dazu neigen sich
generell schlecht zu ernähren sie essen
wahrscheinlich auch mehr zucker oder sie
bewegen sich zum beispiel auch weniger
das bedeutet mit so einem studiendesign
kann man hypothesen aufstellen zum
beispiel die hypothese butter führt zu
herzinfarkt mehr aber auch nicht diese
hypothese muss jetzt erst mal
wissenschaftlich bewegt werden okay wie
geht das ich stärkste methodik die man
beim menschen anwenden kann ist die
sogenannte randomisierte kontrollstudie
so eine studie kann man bei
ernährungsfragen zum beispiel in einem
heim oder so durchführen wo die menschen
jeden tag in der kantine essen
nur so kann man eben kontrollieren was
sie über einen längeren zeitraum essen
dann kann man zwei gruppen erstellen der
testgruppe wo die menschen eben zum
beispiel weniger gesättigte fettsäuren
verabreicht bekommen durch ihr
kontinenten und eine kontrollgruppe die
einfach so weiter essen die bisher
kann man schauen noch mehr zeit ob sich
irgendein gesundheitlich unterschied
zwischen den beiden gruppen beobachten
lässt das problem bei seiner heim
kantinen situation ist natürlich dass
die anzahl und auch die auswahl an
potenziellen versuchsteilnehmern
unglaublich begrenztes wenn man jetzt
eine größere versuchsgruppe oder eine
diverse versuchsgruppe beobachten möchte
da muss man der testgruppe wohl oder
übel sagen wie sie sich ernähren sollen
man kann das ja nicht kontrollieren und
dann kommt man zu dem problem dass
dieser teil der studie nicht blind ist
so sagt man das heißt die
studienteilnehmer wissen was los ist und
das verzerrt die wissenschaftliche
neutralität soll ich sagen die liste der
herausforderungen ist lang und ich kann
ich dazu auch nur dieses video von zu
empfehlen das erklärt warum ernährung
studien so oft widersprüchliche
ergebnisse liefert und deswegen sage ich
auch nichts an ernährung ist einfach und
ich finde es ist unsere verantwortung
als wissenschaftlerinnen eben nicht nur
zu sagen ich informiere sie hier nur sie
können nachher natürlich mit den
informationen tun und lassen was sie
wollen sondern unsere expertise dafür zu
nutzen um differenziert einzuordnen und
ja kokosöl wird lächerlich vermarktet
das kritisiert professor mich absolut
zurecht ich meinen es ist halt wer jetzt
da vitamine oder sonst was sucht der
sollte mal lieber einen apfel beißen
aber wenn man oder wenn ich jetzt mit
meinen infos keine zeit täglich mit
vermitteln dann kommt halt irgendwann
der nächste marketing scan oder der
nächste ernährungstrends und dann fallen
wieder alle drauf rein
ich bin aber absolut dafür mit allen
mitteln aufmerksamkeit auf wissenschaft
zu ziehen und die strecke zum beispiel
auch nicht verkehrt titel zurück dafür
bin ich mir überhaupt nicht zu schade
aber das sollte natürlich nicht auf
kosten der wissenschaftlichen
korrektheit laufen über die art und
weise der wissenschaftskommunikation
hätte ich sehr gerne mit frau professor
michael persönlich diskutiert denn ich
finde man kann sich darüber durchaus
streiten
meine meinung ist zwar klar aber wir
fallen durchaus auch gute argumente für
ihre strategien hätte sie es nicht so
scharf formuliert hätte
überhaupt ihnen zugehört war es fertig
notwendig kokosöl als den ultimativen
bösewicht darzustellen damit man ein
genügend schweres gegengewicht gegen den
hi platz und welche message bleibt
eigentlich auf lange sicht auch ein
spannender punkt irgendwann wendet sich
die ganze aufregung um diesen vortrag
gelegt hat und die leute sich irgendwann
nicht mehr genau an die details erinnern
welche chrome message bleibt hängen ist
es vielleicht einfach nur ich war das
nochmal coco ist doch nicht so gut wie
alle immer sagen das ist ja völlig in
ordnung und letztendlich sollte man es
ja nach möglichkeit vermeiden was denkt
ihr schreibe es in die kommentare
und wenn wir gerade über teko messages
reden am ende ihres vortrags gibt sie
diese in ihren empfehlungen und auch die
kann ich alle nur unterschreiben ganz
einfache regeln nur da
da hätten wir uns gestritten nichts an
ernährung ist einfach wir sehen uns in
der entgeltfrage der sonne
hättet ihr nicht auch gerne ein gerades
video ein problem wenn ihr nach und frau
professor michels die nächste ernährungs
kontroverse auslösen möchte gibt es
dieses einfache template einfach hier
ein derzeit beliebteste nahrungsmittel
einsetzen
new world